[Musik]
im heutigen Video geht es um die sich
widerstrebenden Interessen von gleich
vier großen Nationen Indien den USA
China und Russland jede einzelne von
ihnen möchte durch trägreiches und
mehrdeutiges Taktieren ständig
wechselnder Bündnisse und Konflikte das
Maximum für sich herausholen es ist ein
Spiel mit dem Feuer denn alle vier
Atommächte verfolgen hochgesteckte
nationale wie geostrategische Ambitionen
passend dazu haben wir euch ein Online
PvP Game ausgesucht indem ihr diese
geostrategischen Taktiken mal selbst
ausprobieren könnt ohne dabei das
Schicksal der realen Welt aufs Spiel
setzen zu müssen bevor wir also in die
Geopolitik der realen Großmächte
einsteigen möchten wir euch unseren
Sponsor Konflikt auf nations vorstellen
in Konflikt auf nations übernimmst du
die Kontrolle über die Streitkräfte
einer der globalen die für ihre
militärische Expansion wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung technologische Forschung und
internationale Diplomatie verantwortlich
ist es handelt sich um ein recht
beliebtes langzeitstrategiespiel das auf
dem PC im Webbrowser oder auf dem
gespielt werden kann bei dem in einem
Match bis zu 100 Spieler miteinander um
die globale Vorherrschaft kämpfen du
baust nach und nach deine Infrastruktur
und Streitkräfte auf und beginnst dann
Gegner zu bekämpfen und Direktorium zu
beanspruchen mit den anderen
menschlichen Spielern gegen die du
online antrittst kannst du chatten und
auf diese Art eine vielfältige
Diplomatie entfalten das Konzept der
Langzeitstrategie von Konflikt auf
nations erzeugt dabei eine Art
bestechenden Realismus für das spannende
Ringen um die Weltherrschaft das Spiel
enthält zwar ein paar du den Elemente
ist ansonsten jedoch free to play das
heißt du kannst dir über den Link in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video einen
vollkommen kostenlosen Account
einrichten und dann sowohl auf deinem
Rechner als auch auf deinem Handy
spielen und das Beste wenn du auf den
Link in der Beschreibung klickst
erhältst du als Bonus 13.000 Gold der
ingame Währung und einen ganzen Monat
Premium Abo gratis dazu dieses Angebot
gilt nur für 30 Tage also zögere nicht
zu lange und fange am besten noch heute
damit an deine Truppen zu mobilisieren
neue Allianzen zu Schmied und siegreiche
Schlachten zu planen wie gesagt euch
kostet es gar nichts und uns helft ihr
damit weitere informative Videos zu
drehen also ich sehe los probiert Blick
auf nations mal aus und schnappt euch
jetzt an wir reisen nämlich auf den
Indischen Subkontinent
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum Einstieg eine kleine Vorwarnung
irgendwann im nächsten Jahr wird es
einen Tag geben an dem furchtbar viel
kluge und korrekte Texte von
Schulbüchern über Lexikoneinträge bis
hin zu aber 1.000 von wissenschaftlichen
Artikeln plötzlich nicht mehr korrekt
sein werden und zwar hinsichtlich einer
standardflosse die uns so vertraut
unverlässlich erscheint wie die
Feststellung dass die Erde um die Sonne
kreist China ist das
bevölkerungsreichste Land der Erde tja
das war wohl seit gut 2000 Jahren so
also fünf Mal länger als die 400 Jahre
dieser Galileo Galileis revolutionäre
Erkenntnis wer sich hier um wen dreht
vergangen sind im Jahr 2023 wird China
zwar immer noch von einer gewaltigen
Zahl Menschen bevölkert sein 1,42
Milliarden aber woanders werden eben
schon ein paar Menschen mehr leben
nämlich in Indien und um Indien als
einem gewichtigen Faktor der Weltpolitik
geht es uns heute einerseits wie in den
mit den USA kooperiert aber andererseits
und das ist in den letzten einem etwas
zu einem geopolitischen Reizklima
geworden um Indiens Haltung gegenüber
Russland und der Ukraine also betrachten
wir diesmal nichts Geringeres als die
Beziehungen des allzball
bevölkerungsreichsten Landes der Welt
zum flächenmäßig größten Land der Welt
das ist ihr bekanntlich Russland das
gerade den Versuch unternommen hat
mittels der Annexion von vier
ukrainischen Gebieten sogar noch ein
bisschen größer zu werden und das wohl
in erster Linie deshalb weil Putin an
der Wahnvorstellung leidet über einen
Herrschaftsbereich vom Kaliber der
untergegangenen so wird uniongebieten zu
müssen Putins imperialen Ambitionen
stellen sich neben der angegriffenen
Ukraine vor allem die demokratisch
regierten Länder der Erde entgegen
angeführt wird diese hilfsallianz von
den USA diese sind aber Vorsicht schon
wieder so eine faktenfalle gar nicht die
größte Demokratie der Welt denn das ist
ebenfalls in den ganz vordergründig
betrachtet könnte Indien deshalb wie
eine natürliche Verbündeter der
Vereinigten Staaten erscheinen
demokratisches System Check Amtssprache
Englisch Check nicht gut zu sprechen auf
die Volksrepublik China den größten
rival der USA check doch das heißt jetzt
überhaupt nicht dass ich in den
solidarisch in die reine Putin Gegner
und Ukraine unterstütze aus der
westlichen Welt einreihen würde in ihren
unterstützt putinskrieg zwar nicht aber
die Kritik daran fällt doch sagen wir
mal sehr moderat aus und längst drückte
zwar der indische premier-arena Modi auf
dem Forum der Shanghai Organisation für
Zusammenarbeit Putin für seine
Interventionen der Ukraine mit den
Worten
indischer Premierminister Modi zu
Russlands Bozen jetzt ist nicht die Zeit
des Krieges allerdings hat sich Indien
nicht den westlichen Sanktionen gegen
Russland angeschlossen ganz im Gegenteil
wie solche Meldungen zeigen
Indiens Öl Importe aus Russland sind
seit April um das 50-fache gestiegen 50
mal mehr russische Öl Importe kann man
aber wohl nur zählen wenn man die
vergleichszeiträume schon sehr geschickt
wählt im april 2021 kaufte Indien zum
Beispiel
22.500 russisches Öl pro Tag dieses Jahr
waren es im April über 680.000 Bar das
wären nur 30 mal mehr wir wollen jetzt
aber keine Erbsen zählen ja es handelt
sich um einen gewaltigen Anstieg auch
das sind Finnland ansässige
Forschungszentrum Center for research
und energy and clean air bestätigt den
Porter aus Russland haben seit den
Beginn der russischen Invasion stark
zugenommen bin jetzt Anteil andere ist
ganz ruhelexporten stieg nach Angaben
der Finnen zwischen Februar und Mai von
einem auf 18 Prozent fakt bleibt kaum
hatte die russische Invasion in der
Ukraine begonnen hat Indien angefangen
russisches Öl
einzukaufen als gäbe es kein Morgen
allerdings dass er auch gesagt Indien
ist bei weitem nicht das einzige Land
das die wirtschaftssanktion des Westens
gegen Moskau ignoriert selbst die Türkei
immerhin NATO Mitglied will gar nicht
mitmachen ganz im Gegenteil sie hat
ihren Handel mit Russland stark
ausgebaut und auch in der EU fanden sich
pfiffige Geschäfte machen die weiterhin
russisches Öl angekauft haben wir müssen
dazu gar nicht mal zu Orban gehen
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an Berichte
über heimliche umladungen zwischen
Tankschiffen vor dem Küsten
Griechenlands oder den Verschnitt von
russischen Öl mit westlichen in
elektrischen Raffinerien hauptsache das
Endprodukt bestand nur höchstens zu
49,9% aus russischen Rohstoff sehr
raffiniert und das obwohl wir alle nur
zu gut wissen dass der ölexporters
Rückgrat der russischen Wirtschaft ist
wenn alle Länder aufhören würden den
Russen ihr Öl abzukaufen könnten diese
ihren Krieg in der Ukraine kaum lange
fortführen mit anderen Worten die
Tatsache dass Indien praktisch über
Nacht seine ölkäufe in Russland so
hochgefahren hat könnte für Moskau
geradezu eine Rettungsanker sein
eigentlich müsste man also in Washington
stinksauer sein auf Neu Delhi in der so
offensichtlich das Öl im Barock gegen
Russland unterlaufen und die
US-Regierung müsste mit Konsequenzen
Freundschaft in Zukunft und anderen
Unannehmlichkeiten drohen doch
Pustekuchen
die USA Streben trotz der
russland-sanktionen verstärkte
Waffenverkäufe an Indien an das kriegt
ihr nicht ganz in den Kopf nicht wahr
[Musik]
zweimal schon hat sich seit dem Beginn
des russischen Kriegs Joe Biden mit in
den starken manner Ränder Modi getroffen
den beiden Fällen hat beiden Modi Wohlen
etwa das hier gesagt naranga Modi Öl aus
Russland kaufen ist böse siehst du nicht
was Putin in der Ukraine anstellt das
ist gar nicht nett von dir aber statt
einer Strafe oder wenigstens einem Klaps
auf dem Hintern folgt dann so gleich
hier hast du 500 Millionen Dollar damit
du Waffen kaufen kannst aber Verdienst
hast du sie dir nicht ja da guckst du
die Vereinigten Staaten bereiten doch
tatsächlich ein 500 Millionen Dollar
Paket an Militärhilfe für Indien vor
die USA wollen Indien mit einem
rüstungshilfspaket von russischen Waffen
entwöhnen 500 Millionen Dollar Deal
zwischen Indien und USA möglich Indien
ist größter Abnehmer russischer
Militärtechnik und das obwohl in dir die
Sanktionen gegen Russland ignoriert tja
das alles wirkt natürlich erhebliche
Fragen auf warum unterstützt Indien dass
die Souveränität von Staaten doch immer
groß schreibt ausgerechnet die
Invasionsmacht Russland in diesem Krieg
kann Indien die russische Wirtschaft
wirklich vor den westlichen Sanktionen
außerdem fragen wir uns natürlich auch
warum arbeiten die USA trotz alldem
weiterhin mit Indien in einem
schlüsselsektor wieder Verteidigung
zusammen all diese Fragen werden wir
heute natürlich beantworten zuvor
möchten wir uns noch ganz schnell bei
unserem edlen Spendern bedanken die es
uns ermöglichen noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu drehen danke eure
Unterstützung haben wir es geschafft
unseren schwesterkanal visual
economic.de aufzubauen der nur innerhalb
eines Monats genauso beliebt geworden
ist wie visualpolitik vielen herzlichen
Dank dafür an Euch alle übrigens
arbeiten wir bereits an einem weiteren
Projekt das euch ebenfalls viel Freude
bereiten dürfte ihr dürft also schon
gespannt sein und falls ihr noch nicht
gespendet habt den Link dazu findet ihr
wie immer in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video so und nun schnell zu
unserem Thema Indien und Russland
welches ihr zunächst aus dem
mittlerweile schon traditionell
gewordenen geschichtlichen Blickwinkel
unter die Lupe nehmen werden also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
zwischen zwei Stühlen
1955 gehört Indien zur dritten Welt im
wortwörtlichen Sinne der Begriff Dritte
Welt kamen 1955 auf das sogenannten Band
dunkle Konferenz zur Welt zu dieser
Konferenz kamen in Indonesien alle
Länder zusammen den Kalten Krieg nicht
Partei ergreifen wollten wenn der
kapitalistischer Block die Erste Welt
ist und das verwirrt kommunistische die
zweite Welt dann bildeten sie eben die
Dritte Welt auf der Teilnehmerliste
standen Länder wie Ägypten Iran China
und eben auch Indien erst später bekam
dieser Begriff Dritte Welt einen
abwertenden Klang und verwies auf ein
niedriges Entwicklungsniveau von Staat
aus der Wandung Initiative entstand
später auch die Bewegung der blockfreien
Staaten die gibt es übrigens bis heute
noch auch wenn sie in der Weltpolitik
eigentlich keine Rolle mehr spielt
Indien war dabei geradezu
bilderbuchblockfrei es hatte nach seiner
Unabhängigkeit 1947 ein hybrides System
das zwischen den beiden großen Blöcken
angesiedelt war politisch gesehen ist in
den eine liberale Demokratie wie jedes
andere westliche Land in ökonomischer
Hinsicht war der Subkontinent jedoch
weit von Marktwirtschaft Kapitalismus
entfernt es gehörte zu den sogenannten
elektrovolkswirtschaften und hatte sogar
fünf jahresgelände kommunistischen
Vorbild mit anderen Worten es war ein
durch und durch hybridesland das dazu
bestimmt war mit beiden Blöcken den
westlichen wie dem östlichen auf gutem
Fuß zu stehen
[Musik]
hinzu kommt dass die Sowjetunion im
Gegensatz zum besten Indien wichtigen
Fragen immer auf der Seite nur deliz
stand zum Beispiel hat sie bei allen
unabstimmungen in den in seinem Konflikt
mit Pakistan und Kaschmir unterstützt
die USA zeigt mit dieser Hinsicht immer
eine weitaus an die Valente Reposition
und zwar bis heute
[Musik]
Joe Biden zum Beispiel hat eine
Entscheidung seines Vorgängers Donald
Trump rückgängig gemacht und einen 450
Millionen Dollar Deal mit Pakistan
angekündigt um den erzmann Indiens bei
der Modernisierung seiner F16 Flotte zu
helfen Pakistan wurde hierzu eine ganze
Woche lang in den USA hofiert und den
Pentagon mit einer Ehrengarde und einem
51 Schuss salut empfangen und als wenn
dies noch nicht genug der sticheline
gegen Indien wäre reiste der
US-Botschafter in Pakistan auf die
pakistanische Seite Kaschmirs und nannte
das Gebiet wiederholt mit dem
offiziellen pakistanischen Namen freies
Jambo und Kaschmir Washington
signalisiert nur daily auf diese Weise
immer wieder das ist auch anders kann
allerdings muss man ganz klar sehen dass
immer wenn amerikanische Präsidenten die
Beziehungen zu Islamabad ausgebaut haben
mindestens innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts
die große Ernüchterung kam so dass ihre
jeweiligen Nachfolger feststellen
mussten was für eine schreckliche Idee
dies war siehe hierzu auch unser Video
über das amerikanischen Fiasko in
Afghanistan aber zurück nach Indien was
ist zum Beispiel mit dessen Atomprogramm
nun 19 75 führte in den ersten Test eine
Atombombe durch die Vereinigten Staaten
reagierten mit Wirtschaftssanktionen die
UdSSR hingegen begann Indien mit
schwerem Wasser und nuklearme am Haus zu
versorgen wenn Moskau dachte man wohl je
mehr Atombomben ist auf der Welt gibt
desto besser haben ist unsere Kinder
überhaupt Waffen sind der Grundpfeiler
der indisch russischen Freundschaft
[Musik]
um euch einen Eindruck zu verschaffen
2016 kamen 69% der indischen
Waffenimporte aus Putins Imperium als
klassisches blockfreies Land hat nur
Deli natürlich auch von anderen Ländern
Waffen gekauft unter anderem von den
Vereinigten Staaten sein Hauptlieferant
ist jedoch mit Abstand Russland ja und
warum jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
nun der Hauptgrund ist ganz schlecht
weil sie billiger sind denn russische
Waffen mögen zwar viele Mängel haben
darüber haben wir vor ein paar Monaten
übrigens Video gemacht dass bei den
Zugriffszahlen durch die Decke geht ja
sie haben viele Mängel aber was den
Preis angeht sind Kalaschnikow und Co
eben super konkurrenzfähig wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt geht es dabei nicht nur
um Waffen sondern auch um alles was es
braucht um diese im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes Beschuss zu halten 80% der
Ersatzteile für das indische
Waffenarsenal kommen ebenfalls aus
Russland die indische Einkaufsliste im
russenshop geht aber weit über Waffen
hinaus
[Musik]
wir müssen da vor allem über den
Energiesektor sprechen zwar stimmt es
das Indien kaum Gas in seinem Energie
verwendet nur 6% der indischen
Stromerzeugung stammen aus Erdgas
dennoch hat in den angekündigt das ist
plant in das russische Öl- und
gasprojekt zacharin 1 entfernen Osten
des Landes zu investieren und damit
möglicherweise US-Firmen als Investoren
zu ersetzen bleiben mit Putin erließen
nämlich Anfang Oktober ein Dekret mit
denen das Projekt dass du von Exo und
mobile geleitet wurde einfach vom
russischen Staat im Schlagwort wurde
Indien könnte als auch hier als
kriegsgewinner profitieren der indische
erdölminister hat die Xing sagte dass
nur die prüfen werde was Russland nach
der Überarbeitung der
Eigentumsverhältnisse zu bieten habe und
Flug dazu dass die beiden Länder hierzu
einen gesunden Dialog führten darüber
hinaus haben 2019 die indische Regierung
und das russische Staatsunternehmen auch
eine Absichtserklärung zum Bau von
mindestens sechs neuen Atomreaktoren
getroffen im Moment errichtet das
russische Unternehmen bereits zwei
Reaktoren in Kraftwerk Kuder das ist
Indiens größtes Kernkraftwerk genau
anders zu Ende des Landes gelegen mit
anderen Worten die Beziehungen zwischen
Indien und Russland waren schon immer
ziemlich eng tatsächlich befürworten
sechs und zehn ändern die
Aufrechterhaltung der Beziehungen
zwischen ihrer Regierung und Moskau
trotz des Krieges aber geht es hierbei
jetzt um gemeinsame Werte engagiert
Unterstützung und politischen Beistand
oder einfach nur um knallharte
wirtschaftliche Interessen genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an
[Musik]
einen Schritt nach Osten zwei Schritte
nach Westen
2014 wurde nach einer Modi
Premierminister Indiens aber wer ist
narenda Modi überhaupt was ist seine
Ideologie nun man könnte sagen dass
Moody ein populistischer Führer ist sehr
nationalistisch und wirklich beliebt bei
seinen Bürgern um euch eine Vorstellung
zu geben seine Partei hat mehr als 60%
der Sitze im Unterhaus und welche
Ideologie vertritt dieser Mann und
zusammenfassen könnte man sagen das
Modis Programm auf drei Säulen beruht
zum ersten konstatieren wir bei ihm
ultra Nationalismus nebeneinander Modi
wird ein Donald Trump wie der letzte
vaterlandslose Geselle die zweite Säule
seiner Regierung ist die Technokratie
Modi kam mit den Versprechen an die
Macht die überbürokratisierung Indiens
zu beenden die Ergebnisse seiner
Verwaltungsreform sind dabei aber sagen
wir mal ja fragwürdig aber wartet die
dritte Säule der Moderierung wird euch
aus den Socken haut engere Beziehungen
zum Besten
und ihr könnt mir glauben in dieser
Hinsicht kommt nach Arena movies
Diplomatie ziemlich aufgeklärt daher
obwohl er eine größerer Trump ist als
Trump selbst war Modi gut Freund mit
Barack Obama mehr noch Obama ging sogar
so weit ein Porträt für das Teil mal
gesehen zu schreiben in denen er den in
der geradezu seine unsterbliche Liebe
verkündete es überrascht auch nicht dass
ich neu.de und Washington während der
Trump Amtszeit Blenden verstanden haben
und jetzt werdet ihr euch ganz zurecht
fragen was heißt das denn eigentlich
genauer sich dem Westen anzunähern also
außer puren Männerfreundschaften 0 unter
anderem bedeutet es alle Arten von
sicherheitsallianzen zu schließen und
dabei geht es vor allem darum sich gegen
einen von Indiens größten Gegnern zu
verteidigen von wem hier die Rede ist
Pakistan aber nicht doch Pakistan ist
ein ewiger Erzfeind aber nicht die
größte Bedrohung Indiens es geht um
einen anderen vielmächtigeren und
furchterregeneren Gegner die sogenannte
Volksrepublik China und das erklärt zum
Beispiel warum in den Teil des Quad ist
das ist ein strategisches Bündnis dass
die Vereinigten Staaten Australien kann
und Indien umfasst es handelt sich dabei
um ein geopolitisches Projekt mit einer
ziemlich konkreten Aufgabenstellung ein
strategisches Gegengewicht zu China zu
schaffen und neben reiner Diplomatie
beschäftigt man sich da auch mit harten
Fakten genauer gesagt mit Rüstungsgütern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie wir in unserem schon erbinden Video
über den russischen militärischen
industriellen Komplex gezeigt haben
russische Waffen sind billig aber sie
treffen nicht unbedingt besser als
verzogene Schrotflinten an einer
jahrmarktschicht wurde wer uns das nicht
glaubt sollte sich halt einfach das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine genauer
ansehen und ihr könnt euch sicher
vorstellen dass es mit so einem
potenziellen Mangel behafteten Arsenal
schwierig ist ein immer mächtigeres
China abzuschrecken denn so in nur Delhi
als auch in Peking blickt man mit
Entsetzen auf die mega face der
russischen Waffensysteme in der Ukraine
wenn auch das Entsetzen jeweils andere
Gründe hat dich Chinesen werden
zunehmend nervöser weil sie merken dass
sie sich strategisch mit einem Big Time
loser verbündet haben aber immerhin
haben sie noch ihre eigenen Waffen den
indischen Streitkräften ist hingegen
vollkommen klar dass von den
katastrophalen Testergebnissen der
russischen Waffen in der Ukraine ihre
eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit direkt
betroffen ist Indien muss also auch in
der Lage sein auf westliche Waffen
zurückzugreifen sonst ist es dem roten
Drachen ausgeliefert tja und deswegen
verschwendet wie keine Zeit dass man
einen Blick auf diese Daten
[Musik]
vor 2016 kam fast 70 Prozent der
indischen Waffenimporte aus Russland
jetzt sind es weniger als 30 Prozent an
der Spitze liegt jetzt Frankreich unter
anderem wegen eines Militärdienst über
die Lieferung von 36 Grad fallham
stellst aber ihr denkt euch jetzt sicher
wenn russische Waffen deswegen so
attraktiv sind weil sie billig zu haben
sind heißt das ja ein Umkehrschluss gute
westliche Militärtechnik muss teuer sein
egal ob aus den USA oder aus Frankreich
und ja das ist sie das Problem indien
hat gar nicht so viel Geld deswegen hat
es ihr auch jahrelang beim russenwisch
bestellt was ist also die Lösung
und die Lösung besteht zum Beispiel
darin Joint Ventures mit indischen
Unternehmen zu gründen das heißt ein
amerikanischer Hersteller schließt mit
einem indischen Hersteller einen Vertrag
um zum Beispiel Flugzeuge zu produzieren
das bringt deutliche Kosteneinsparungen
mit sich und ein Teil des Geldes bleibt
so auch im Lande
und auch wenn ein solches Produkt
vielleicht in seinen Leistungsdaten der
US-Version etwas nachstehen dürfte ist
doch effektiver sein als das russische
Pendant schön und gut aber es gibt da
ein Problem mit solchen Abkommen und
zwar das Indien immer noch ein stark
zentralisiertes Land ist die
Rüstungsindustrie wird von
hyperbürokratisierten staatskonzernen
beherrscht es geht da um Unternehmen wie
hindustran arroonotics limited der
Bedarf an mehr Flexibilität erklärt
warum nur die 2020 die Tür weit für
ausländische Investoren geöffnet hat die
nun bis zu 74% eines
rüstungsunternehmens besitzen können
davon unabhängig sind zwischen den USA
und in dem Bereich so einige negativ in
Rüstungssektor am reif
Lockheed Martin und Tata advance Systems
unterzeichnen einen wegweisendes
Abkommen indem die Unternehmen ihre
Absicht bekräftigen gemeinsam die F16
Block 70 in Indien zu produzieren dieser
Kampfjet soll übrigens nicht mehr F16
sondern F21 heißen aber das ganze
Waffenarsenal einer Großmacht um zu
krempeln das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen
Russland bleibt für Indien sowohl im
Verteidigungs als auch Energiebereich
wichtig und vor allem deshalb hat Mondi
beschlossene Russland nicht zu
sanktionieren aber ist das nun eine gute
oder eine schlechte Idee wir von
visualpolitik wollen ihm dafür
sicherlich keinen Applaus spenden aber
eines ist sicher in den profitiert sehr
von dieser Situation
in den Versuch seine Energiequellen mit
billigem russischen Öl zu
diversifizieren um euch eine Vorstellung
zu geben vor dem Krieg haben nur 0,5 bis
1 % der indischen Ölversorgung aus
Russland jetzt sind es mehr als 10%
schnelllenker unter euch werden jetzt
sagen aha so kann Russland und Business
also Thorsten Sanktionen Mund erwachsen
anstatt Öl an die Europäer zu verkaufen
vertickt man das jetzt halt an Indien
das dreimal mehr Bevölkerung hat als die
EU stimmt nun nee
denn in Wirklichkeit ist es nur Delhi
das hier einen bombendeal gemacht hat
ein mega Schnäppchen sondergleichen da
die USA und Europa den Kauf von
russischem
Ölpreis dieses Mal wieder in
astronomische Höhle stiegen zeitweise
lag der Preis für ein Barrel der Sorte
brennt bei über 120 US-Dollar trotz
alledem keine reiches Land wollte Öl aus
Russland kaufen und da kam Indien daher
und sagte Russland man treuer Freund
Genosse und trovarisch sei unbesorgt ich
bin hier um dir dann Öl abzukaufen aber
da ich praktisch der einzige Interessent
bin du wirst es mir doch zu einem
günstigen Preis überlassen oder wie wäre
es mit einem Rabatt von 30 $ pro Barrel
russland hatte keine andere Wahl als
diese Bedingungen zu erfüllen kurz um in
den Kauf in Russland Öl weit unter dem
Marktpreis bei diesem Geschäft geht es
also eher wenig um Ideologie oder
brüderliche Hilfe es gibt sehr viel
darum die gegebene Situation günstig
auszunutzen Opportunismus eben nur mal
so zum Vergleich Europa importierte vor
dem großen Krieg mehr als 3, wäre pro
Tag aus Russland Indien kauft jetzt etwa
680.000 Wert pro Tag und das zu einem
viel geringeren Preis mit anderen Worten
sollte Europa als bald ganz aufhören Öl
aus Russland zu kaufen was er schon
beschlossene Sache ist dort Indien nicht
in der Lage sein diese Verluste
auszugleichen weder beim Preis noch bei
der Menge ähnlich sieht es übrigens auch
bei den anderen Klassikern im russischen
Angebot aus und das obwohl indes
Einfuhren an Kohle ebenfalls ein vom
Besten sanktioniertes Exportgut und
Düngemittel aus Russland in diesem Jahr
ebenfalls drastisch angestiegen sind so
weit so gut oder auch ungut aber um
jetzt wieder auf die USA zurückzukommen
warum intensiviert beiden dennoch die
Zusammenarbeit mit Indien und das werden
wir uns als nächstes ansehen
[Musik]
wie Perlenkette
für die USA gilt neben Russland vor
allem China als Gerüste Bedrohung der
westlichen Sicherheit in dieser Hinsicht
könnten in dieses Interessen also gar
nicht besser mit denen des Westens
übereinstimmen in dieser Hinsicht hat
Indien aber auch eine Menge zu verlieren
ihr wisst vielleicht dass China und
Indien Grenzstreitigkeiten aller Art
haben alle paar Jahre gibt es einen
schachmützel an der Grenze hoch oben im
Himalaya über diesen indisch
chinesischen Konflikt haben wir schon
vor einiger Zeit ein eigenes Video
gedreht dass ich euch verlinken werde
aber die größte Bedrohung ist Zweifels
oder nun schaut euch mal diese Karte an
was wir hier seht ist die
perlenkettenstrategie es geht um eine
Reihe von Häfen die von China finanziert
werden und strategische so platziert
sind dass sie Indien geradezu ein
Kreisen wir sprechen hier von Häfen in
Pakistan Sri Lanka und Bangladesch
theoretisch sind diese Hilfen für zivile
Nutzung gedacht aber sie werden von
China finanziert und Pakistan Sri Lanka
und Bangladesch sind sehr schwache
Volkswirtschaften so dass China Sie
jederzeit unter Druck setzen kann damit
die chinesische Marine von dort aus
operieren könnte schon seit Jahren in
China das aus was wir hier bei
visualpolitik Sugar Daddy Diplomatie
nennen wir haben solche
Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse schon in
früheren Videos erklärt auch diese werde
ich euch verlinken damit ihr den
vollständigen Überblick bekommt kurz
gesagt China kann diese Hefen sehr
leicht für militärische Zwecke
umfunktionieren und das ist eine
ziemlich heftige Bedrohung für Indiens
Sicherheit daraus erklären sich dann
alle diplomatischen und militärischen
Allianzen neu-delis mit Washington ihr
fragt euch aber vielleicht was könnte
aber Indien seinerseits zur Abschreckung
oder Eindämmung Chinas beitragen nun
eine ganze Menge vor allem eine Sache
ist dabei entscheidend seine
geografische Lage schaut euch dazu diese
Karte hier an
[Musik]
was ihr hier seht ist die Straße von
Malaka eines der Epizentren des
Welthandels mehr als 70% des Erdgases
und erdösti China erreichen wird hier
geradezu durch ein Nadelöhr geschleust
es würde genügend die Durchfahrt von
Schiffen für kurze Zeit zu blockieren um
die chinesische Wirtschaft von einem
Moment auf den anderen in allerhöchste
Bedrängnis zu bringen und welches Land
kann diesen Verkehr ideal blockieren
exakt Indien und wie könnte es das tun
nun ganz einfach seht ihr diese
Inselkette hier das sind die Andamanen
und Nikobaren Inseln sie sind ein
zumindest für ostasiatische Verhältnisse
praktisch kaum gewohnter Archipel der
ausgerechnet zu indien gehört bis vor
ein paar Jahrzehnten waren diese Inseln
nur für die dort lebenden Eingeborenen
Stämme von Bedeutung doch in letzter
Zeit ändert sich dort so einiges gesehen
neuer Marinestützpunkt auf den Andamanen
stärkt Indiens militärische Position im
Indischen Ozean das erklärt warum die
Vereinigten Staaten so sehr daran
interessiert sind die Beziehungen zu
Indien zu verbessern den Gegenüber ist
das was in dir mit Russland macht er
zwei drei Washington ist daran
interessiert dass neu-delien anständiges
Militär hat es in der Lage ist China im
Zaum zu halten alles andere ist wirklich
zweitrangig außerdem warum ist es für
Indien so verlockend Öl aus Russland zu
kaufen
[Musik]
hauptsächlich weil es eben billig ist
und war da nicht was ja zum Zeitpunkt
Erstellung dieses Videos liegt im Westen
schon einige Zeit eine Debatte über die
Einführung einer Preisobergrenze für
russisches Erdöl die G7 Länder also die
führenden Volkswirtschaft der westlichen
Welt wollen eine Höchstpreise Öl aus
Russland festlegen damit dieser
preisdeckel funktioniert müssen alle
großen Handelsnationen zustimmen doch
scheint es das Indien nicht bereit ist
mitzumachen zumindest nicht zum
gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt die Frage dabei
ist allerdings macht das überhaupt einen
großen Unterschied denn wenn Indien Öl
von Russland kauft dann deshalb weil
Russland sein Öl den Kindern
gezwungenermaßen weit unter Marktpreis
liefert mit anderen Worten es ist
vollkommen egal ob die Ausgaben formal
gedeckelt werden oder anders Indien ist
nur dann an Sibirien schwarzen Gott
interessiert wenn es der Wege zu einem
sehr sehr günstigen Preis bekommt so
gesehen hat nur Delhi den Ölpreis Deckel
für Moskau eigentlich schon vor den USA
und der EU eingeführt auch wenn es immer
wieder betont sich diesen dabei nicht
anschließen zu wollen um Russland nicht
Sequenz vor den Kopf zu stoßen dieses
jahresköpfige agieren Indien
symbolisiert eigentlich am besten die
Natur des indisch-russischen
Verhältnisses es geht Neu Delhi in
erster Linie um Geld danach kommt Geld
dann lange nichts dann irgendwann
vielleicht mal Waffen aber nicht mehr so
wie früher und das Wasser auch schon
Russland wird Ende 2022 ein weit weniger
attraktiver Partner für Indien sein als
es noch zu Beginn des Jahres war seinen
Sexappeal als Waffenlieferant hat es
vollständig verloren und Gegensatz zu
China kann sich in den langfristig kaum
auf russische Energie Rohstoffe
verlassen auch wenn es in den letzten
Monaten ein paar kurzfristige
Schnäppchen gemacht hat Indien liegt
aufgrund seiner demografischen Struktur
vor allem Wert auf globale Stabilität
und Moskau hat sich als zutiefst
destabilisierende Kraft erwiesen denn Öl
und Gas sind nicht alles und Moskau ist
Angriffskrieg hat auch das globale
nahrungsmittelsystem extrem
destabilisiert die schmerzhaften
Auswirkungen von
Versorgungsunterbrechungen auf der
ganzen Welt betreffen dabei
überproportional die Länder mit
niedrigem Einkommen und einer großen
Armutsbevölkerung wie eben Indien die
unterbrech sehr Düngemittel und
Energielieferungen hat die
landwirtschaftliche Produkte
beeinträchtigt und gefährdet
gleichzeitig die Transport die
Verarbeitung und den Verkauf von Reschen
Obst Fleisch und Gemüse die für die
Ernährung der dortigen Bevölkerung
wichtig sein da die Inflation die
Ressourcen armafamilien zuerst aufzehrt
wird der Konsum von sicheren und
nahrhaften Lebensmittel voraussichtlich
zurückgehen wodurch auch in Indien eine
ernsthafte Gesundheitskrise entstehen
könnte der Anstieg der Weltmarktpreise
für Weizen und Sonnenblumenöl aufgrund
des Krieges in der Ukraine hat sich
bereits negativ auf die Menschen in
Indien ausgewirkt in Indien ist zum
Beispiel der größte Speiseöl importer
der Welt und ist mit seinem
milliardenbevölkerung gezwungen etwa 90%
des Gesamtbedarfs an Rom Sonnenblumenöl
und 10% aller Speiseöle zu importieren
es ist aber auch von der Einfuhr vieler
weitere essentieller Lebensmittel wie
weizengerste meist uns Sonnenblumenöl
abhängig jetzt größtenteils aus der
Ukraine und Russland bezogen hat die
Einspareffekte durch günstige
Energieimporte aus Russland konnten die
durch Corona und den russischen Krieg
ausgelösten hohen Preissteigerungen bei
Lebensmitteln und anderen Gütern dabei
nicht im geringsten ausgleichen deswegen
wird man sich in nicht genau überlegen
ob es sich wirklich lohnt den globalen
Störenfried Russland auch über ein paar
Schnittchen die es hinaus unterstützen
und die USA und den besten damit
langfristig zu verärgern man weiß zwar
dass die Unterstützung großlands Indien
nicht sofort Schaden wird aber für die
Transformation und Modernisierung der
indischen Wirtschaft im nächsten
Jahrzehnt und die Zukunft der vielen
jungen in der wird das westliche
Investitionen Technologien Märkte und
nicht zuletzt Waffen viel mehr brauchen
als die fragwürdige Partnerschaft mit
einem untergehenden Russland Indien das
wie eingangs erwähnt in Sachen
Einwohnerzahl als bald größte Land der
Erde wird also langfristig nicht viel
dazu beitragen die Wirtschaft des mit
abstandsflächenmäßig größten Landes
Russland am Leben zu erhalten wobei auch
unklar ist ob Russland das dauerhaft
bleiben wird schließlich gibt es ja auch
viele Experten die im Falle einer
Niederlage des Kreml in der Ukraine und
einem Sturz des putin-regimes einen
Kollaps Russland Auseinanderbrechen des
viel Völker reichsprodostiziert so wie
es 1991 schon des Sowjetunion
widerfahren ist auch das kam damals ja
reichlich unerwartet aber fast nur am
Rande zurück zum Thema Indien unser
Fazit lautet im Moment sieht es nicht so
aus als würde es Washington besonders
interessieren ob und welche Deals in den
mit Russland macht und welchen Gewinn
Indien auf diese Weise aus dem Ukraine
Krieg zieht das wichtigste für die USA
ist und bleibt in den Positionen
gegenüber China seine Rolle als
strategisches Gegengewicht zu Peking in
asiatischen Raum Indien was ich auch
alleine sehr bald daran erinnern warum
ist seit mehr als einem Jahrzehnt die
gemeinsamen Werte mit dem besten immer
wieder betont denn diese gemeinsamen
Werte sind es die dabei helfen
vorübergehende Meinungsverschiedenheiten
zu überbrücken eine Möglichkeit die es
in einer kalten berechnenden allein auf
wirtschaftlichen und
transaktionsorientierten Interessen
basierenden Beziehung nicht gibt ein
genauer Blick auf die indischen Aktionen
zeigt daher das Indien weder die
russische Invasion unterstützt noch wie
zu Zeiten des Kalten Krieges ausgewogen
zwischen den zwei Machtblöcken
balanciert stattdessen ist ein subtiler
aber wichtiger Wandel in deine Indiens
langsam aber unausweichliche Abkopplung
von Russland diese Neuorientierung
begann erst vor dem Einmarsch in die
Ukraine aber der Krieg hat sie
beschleunigt tatsächlich löst sich nur
die langsam aus der Abhängigkeit von
Moskau versucht er den Spieß umzukehren
und Russland von sich abhängig zu machen
der tief verwurzelte Anti-Amerikanismus
denn in Indiens Alter strategische Elite
fest verankert war verschwindet Indien
und die USA stehen sich heute näher als
Jesu vor beigetragen hat dazu auch die
starke Annäherung Russlands an den
großen indischen Erzfeind China wenn es
beispielsweise in Chinesisch indischen
Grenzgebiet in Himalaya erneut zuschauen
müssen könnte China Druck auf Russland
ausüben die Lieferung von Waffen und
Munition ein neu-deli einzustellen etwas
was die indische Regierung als
existenzielle Herausforderung für die
nationale Sicherheit ansieht die
Konturen des künftigen geopolitischen
Raumes sind also klar Indien wird sich
eher den besten und den USA annähern um
sich gegen China abzusichern und sich im
Zuge dessen aus seiner langjährigen
Partnerschaft mit Russland zurückziehen
diese Abkopplung wird sich nicht über
Nacht vollziehen und indische und
russische Diplomaten werden die
Beziehungen weiterhin aufrechterhalten
so es eben geht vielleicht sogar über
mehrere Jahre aber größere geopolitische
Zwänge werden Indien Russland
unweigerlich auseinandertreiben und an
diesem Punkt wollen wir mit unseren
traditionellen Fragen einhaken glaubt
ihr das in denen jemals eine gesamte
Armee mit westlichen Waffen ausrüsten
wird und wäre es eine gute Idee Druck
auf in den auszuüben damit ist sich den
Sanktionen gegen Russland anschließt wie
immer sind wir auf eure angerichtete
Diskussion zu diesem kontroversen Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ich
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
was ja gibt uns bitte ein Like das mit
euren Freunden und vergessen das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen vergesst bitte auch nicht
das zu diesem Video vortrefflich
passende Online-Spiel unseres Sponsors
Konflikt auf nations auszuprobieren wenn
du dich Vision zuführen über
militärische Strategien spekulieren
willst solltest du es unbedingt über den
Link in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video anspielen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen in PayPal Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]